[Musica]
noi siamo le storie che ricordiamo è
allora dobbiamo cominciare da una storia
le storie che attraversano il tempo e lo
spazio
sono le storie che ci definiscono questa
storia comincia in mare è un mare mosso
c'è una barca che lo sta solcando i
marinai remano a fatica sanno che il
mare e morte perché nell odissea il mare
morte e attraversamento dell'ignoto e
definizione del mondo e di se stessi
legato all'albero di questa nave c'è
l'eroe che tutti conosciamo
ulisse a un certo punto improvvisamente
in questo mare mosso
si fa calma piatta bonaccia e la paura
coglie qualsiasi marinaio che sa che se
non c'è un filo di vento arrivare in
porto diventa difficile e in questo
silenzio quasi mistico si sente un
sussurro sono voci di donne dolcissime
sono le voci di donne che hanno un corpo
ben strano il loro corpo non è come
quello che ci siamo immaginati con i
cartoni animati e un corpo di uccelli ma
la loro voce dolcissima e promettono di
raccontare ai marinai di questa barca
che cosa succede sulla terra e in
particolare che cosa è successo durante
la guerra di [ __ ]
ora voi dovete dirmi tutti sapete che
sto parlando delle sirene di ulisse che
razza di tentazione è questa
uno che sta tornando almeno ci sta
provando e vent'anni
che ci prova a tornare dalla guerra di
[ __ ]
tu come promessa gli dici come
tentazione gli dici io ti racconterò
quello che tu hai già vissuto capite che
è una tentazione ben strana e perché
questo nostro eroe si è legato
all'albero della nave vuole ascoltare
esattamente questo canto che riguarda la
storia da cui lui sta avvenendo per
sapere se quella storia è entrata nella
storia nel mondo greco entrare nel
racconto epico significa avere
finalmente un'identità ogni cultura si
struttura attorno a questo gran questa
grande sfida
come facciamo a non far cadere il nostro
nome nel nulla
la nascita è un accadere che non ci
siamo scelti e la nostra più grande
paura è che ritorneremo nel nulla da cui
siamo venuti ulisse vuole sapere se il
suo nome è finalmente entrato nella
storia e questo vale la pena di una
tentazione come quella delle sirene ma
quando la nave affianca l'isola delle
sirene quello che c'è attorno agli
scogli sono solo ossa di uomini tutti
noi qua dentro abbiamo questo stesso
problema la mattina ci alziamo e
cerchiamo una ragione
una prestazione attraverso la quale
finalmente possiamo essere qualcuno e
questo genera in noi quella paura di
vivere quella stanchezza di vivere come
la chiama un filosofo perché perché
abbiamo trasformato il nostro io in una
prestazione le nostre vite assomigliano
a delle cipolle
abbiamo tanti strati con cui cerchiamo
di definire la nostra identità ma il
nucleo profondo non si sa dove sia
andato a finire
io sono di questa città io faccio questo
lavoro e cerchiamo di costruire sulla
periferia del nostro io identità in modo
che
il nostro essere non cada nel nulla
perché ve lo ripeto noi abbiamo un unico
problema come si fa a non far cadere le
cose nel nulla e questo ci fa paura
questo ci stanca e ogni cultura trova la
sua soluzione
quando incontro i genitori dei miei
alunni le rare volte in cui vengono
entrambi perché sembra che l'educazione
oggi sia demandata solo alle mamme cari
papà venite a parlare con noi insegnanti
i vostri figli saranno fieri del fatto
che avete preso un ora di permesso per
loro dico loro adesso capisco che cosa
perché vostro figlio è così perché i
vostri figli non assomigliano a ciascuno
di voi preso singolarmente assomigliano
alla relazione che c'è tra voi perché
l'unico modo che all'uomo di nascere e
di rinascere sempre essere generato e
solo quando c'è una relazione c'è un
principio che fa nascere nuovo quel
nucleo di essere che ci consente quella
permanenza nell'esistenza che non
dipende da cose che continuamente ci
espongono e finalmente potremmo tirare
un sospiro di sollievo per questo è
importante
l'appello al mattino io credo che la più
grande rivoluzione nella scuola
contemporanea soprattutto quella
italiana dipenda da come facciamo un
appello la natura per gli animali
provvede al fatto che tirino fuori
corazze artigli e zanne per potere
sopravvivere nell'ambiente in cui il
cucciolo di animale da subito deve
arrangiarsi e perché invece il cucciolo
d'uomo ci mette così tanto tempo ad
arrangiarsi
perché il cucciolo di uomo e contro
evolutivo mantiene la sua fragilità
perché la fragilità obbliga gli altri
uomini alla cura è questo che ci
differenzi differenzia dagli animali i
nostri artigli le nostre corazze delle
nostre zanne fanno qui e qui la
relazione è dare all'altro ciò di cui
l'altro ha bisogno quando bevete un
bicchiere d'acqua vi dissetate siete
entrati in contatto con una relazione la
cosa più semplice h2o due atomi di
idrogeno e uno di ossigeno è una
relazione ciascuno dall'altro ciò di cui
l'altro ha bisogno
ed è solo la relazione che genera e
rigenera una persona in un'epoca in cui
ci illudiamo di poter guadagnare tempo e
lottiamo per guadagnare il tempo
espressione assurda come se noi non
fossimo parte del tempo
noi non siamo non abbiamo il tempo a
disposizione siamo a disposizione del
tempo l'unica maniera di guadagnare
tempo e crescere è l'unica maniera di
crescere e nascere sempre nuovi allora
io mi sono divertito a ridefinire le età
della vita nell'arte di essere fragili a
partire proprio da questo elemento è
invalso ormai questa idea che le tappe
della vita siano su una linea retta
c'è un inizio e poi per un principio
quasi inerziale arriveremo ai titoli di
coda
e allora siamo lì che lottiamo
per conquistare quella permanenza per
sapere se siamo entrati nel grande
racconto e se ci fosse un altra
soluzione se potessimo veramente essere
felici senza doverlo dimostrare a
nessuno
non sarà che l'essere vivente vive nella
misura in cui è generato e rigenerato e
allora generare questi vostri figli non
avviene una volta per tutte avviene ogni
santo giorno in cui qualcuno decide di
mettere di nuovo al mondo quella persona
soltanto così guadagniamo tempo e
facciamo guadagnare tempo agli altri
perché non smettiamo di crescere di
farli crescere la vita non assomiglia a
una linea retta assomiglia a una spirale
tutte le volte che noi siamo vicini al
centro che genera questo nucleo di
novità che ciascuno di noi è perché
nascere essere un inedito al mondo
nessuno di noi qua dentro alle impronte
digitali uguali nessuno di noi sa
l'iride degli occhi uguale
tanto che ormai i nostri oggetti
tecnologici ci riconoscono così e noi
amiamo siri amiamo cortana guardiamo
quello schermo in media 200 volte al
giorno
immaginatevi di guardare 200 volte al
giorno vostro figlio vostra figlia così
all'improvviso per 200 volte dice ma sei
scemo
no è che sei importante è che non c'è
stato mai niente come te sulla faccia
della terra è esattamente quello che noi
cerchiamo da quegli oggetti che sappiano
che noi siamo unici ma non c'è un altro
modo di saperlo
sì ma il faticoso la vita è una spirale
più siamo vicini a questo centro mentre
avanza più la nostra vita vive e si
amplia più ci allontaniamo la nostra
vita si disgrega e qual è allora il modo
in cui le tappe della vita si realizzano
io mi sono divertita attraverso le
parole di un poeta ridefinirle perché
non c'entrano niente con una linea retta
che cosa dell'adolescenza che noi
dobbiamo mantenere per tutta la vita che
cos'è della maturità che noi dobbiamo
mantenere per tutta la vita
e l'ora ridefinito la vita in questo
modo l'adolescenza come arte di sperare
la maturità come arte di morire
la terza età o riparazione come arte di
essere fragili è l'ultima a morire o
arti di rinascere nell'adolescenza
quello che accade perché l'arte
disperare perché per la prima volta
emerge il copione inedito che ciascuno
di questi ragazzi è venuto a raccontare
e non c'è più la facile soluzione
dettata dal piacere o dall obbligo che è
tipica del bambino che tutto ciò che
vuole lo ottiene con il pianto
l'inedito finalmente viene alla luce del
motivo per cui un ragazzo una ragazza
sente per la prima volta che la libertà
è nelle sue mani ed è pronto a rompere
qualsiasi muro purché quell'inedito si
realizzi ed è questo che rende un
ragazzo protagonista nella sua vita
protagonista una parola bellissima
antica che indica colui che combatte in
prima fila colui che combatte per primo
ma nessuno combatte se non è un motivo
per cui combattere e l'adolescenza il
momento in cui quell'ardore che noi
possiamo chiamare rapimento vocazione
come volete voi
finalmente
entra nell'esistenza attraverso la
relazione con il mondo capiamo che cosa
siamo venuti a portare io mi ricordo
quando il mio insegnante di lettere mi
chiamò a tu per tu mi disse alessandro
questo è il mio libro di poesie
preferito telo presto fra due settimane
melo restituisci io quel giorno sono
diventato insegnante perché
quell'insegnante mi confidava il suo
segreto vedeva in me qualche cosa che io
davanti allo specchio non potevo vedere
ecco che cos'è quell'appello e il fatto
che nel mio sguardo quando chiamò quel
nome loro devono vedere che io intuisco
amorevolmente già la storia che si
compirà non la conosco ma so che il mio
credo a come argomenti di fede
professore vuol dire professare i nomi
ei cognomi di quei ragazzi per questo
quei nomi e cognomi sono più importanti
della lezione e poi inizia la seconda
fase pieni di questo ardore di questo
slancio vocazionale pensiamo che il
mondo ci stia aspettando e la maturità
allora è l'arte di morire perché uno
dopo l'altro invece accadrà che verranno
smontate tutte le cose che pensiamo di
dover portare in questo mondo e che
nessuno ci sta aspettando
ma siccome ci siamo svincolati dal
principio di piacere del bambino
sappiamo impariamo che quel fuoco si
nutre degli ostacoli che incontra
immaginatevi michelangelo che di fronte
a un blocco di marmo osasse dire che noi
a questo marmo di carrara e così duro e
invece è proprio quella durezza quella
resistenza che ci consegna dei
capolavori come quelli che ha fatto
michelangelo ma capite che questo libera
un adolescente da quella pretesa quel
delirio narcisistico che è tipico poi di
chi rimane bambino di non esplorare il
mondo perché non c'è niente da esplorare
ma di usare il mondo semplicemente per
una propria conferma esplora il mondo
solo chi ha trovato una ragione per
morire
allora la maturità e arte di morire
senza perdere quell'ardore
dell'adolescenza e si entra allora nella
terza età la riparazione o arte di
essere fragili che dipende solo da una
cosa dalla qualità delle relazioni che
noi abbiamo con il mondo e con gli altri
dire ti amo a una persona ormai è
diventato troppo semplice provate a
scrivere ogni tanto al posto di ti amo
tu non devi morire e io mi impegnerò
perché questo non accada
ve lo ripeto tu non devi morire io mi
impegnerò perché questo non accada amare
una persona e farsi custodi del suo
destino come quell'insegnante che mi
prestò il libro quel giorno perché
quella mattina quell'insegnante non
stava pensando all'ennesima giornata di
scuola noiosa da affrontare ea degli
alunni fastidiosi da sopportare
nella sua biblioteca tirato fuori il
libro che poteva servire al suo alunno
perché la relazione sicura quando si
dall'altro ciò di cui l'altro ha bisogno
e ci si prende cura del mondo così solo
quando si ha qualche cosa da portare nel
mondo
se io oggi a 40 anni sono un insegnante
felice e perché a 17 anni un uomo mi ha
prestato il suo libro di poesie
preferito sembra che io stia raccontando
l'acqua la cosa più semplice ma l'acqua
è una relazione h2o dare all'altro ciò
di cui l'altro ha bisogno e allora poi
potremo permetterci anche di entrare
nella fase finale della nostra vita ma
tanto non è quella finale morire o arte
di rinascere
e proprio questo quando una persona sa
qual è l'inedito che è venuto a scrivere
su questa terra
la lotta che fa ogni giorno per
realizzarlo
negli altri prima che in se stesso e ciò
che gli garantisce di aver fatto
qualcosa di bello al mondo che si è
conosciuta 1 dagli altri
non importa
e allora tutte le volte che faccio un
appello quello che dovrei fare mettermi
in ginocchio di fronte a quei 20 25
volti che sono proprio il mondo che mi
viene
affidato la prima volta che ulisse entra
in scena nell odissea sta piangendo
perché gli eroi veri hanno le lacrime
più di tutti e perché sta piangendo
perché ha nostalgia di itaca di sua
moglie di suo figlio di suo padre
calypso la dea immortale bellissima se
ne stupisce e gli chiede perché piangi
perché sei fragile perché sei mortale e
ulisse risponde perché casa mia e oltre
questo mare e le dice no ma rimani con
me io ti renderò immortale e poi sono
molto più bella di penelope gentile
calypso queste idee che non sanno cos'è
la morte non sanno neanche cos'è amare e
ulisse risponde e vero tu sei più bella
di penelope
ma lei e mia moglie e lei che ho scelto
e per questo ulisse sceglie la mortalità
sceglie la fragilità sceglie un isola
piccola è abbastanza inospitale perché
li aspettano il figlio telemaco il padre
laerte la moglie penelope e per questo
lo ricorderemo nei secoli dei secoli
perché ciò che definisce la nostra vita
è ciò che noi sappiamo amare ciò che
definisce la nostra vita è ciò che noi
sappiamo mare allora mi piace chiudere
con i versi di un poeta morto a 50 anni
di cancro che ha voluto che sulla sua
tomba ci fosse scritto quello che aveva
vergato universi della sua ultima poesia
hai avuto quello che volevi dalla vita
nonostante tutto si è che cosa volevi
volevo
potermi dire amato volevo sentirmi amato
sulla terra
ciò che sappiamo amare e ciò che non ci
sarà strappato ciò che sappiamo mare la
nostra eredità il resto è storia
ciò che sappiamo mare è la nostra storia
[Applauso]